broadcasting from berlin this is a dw
news special edition
on india's unfolding coronavirus crisis
more than a million and a half cases
in just a week and thousands of deaths
every day
india is overwhelmed crematoriums are
working overtime
hospitals can't take in more patients
and some medical supplies
are running low how did it come to this
and will things get worse before they
get better
i'm biresh banerjee welcome to this dw
news special
on the tsunami that india's second wave
of covet cases
has turned out to be but it's a tsunami
that hits the country
every day in case numbers more than 380
000 in the past 24 hours
and in the numbers of dead more than 3
500.
dw's india bureau chief amrita chima is
reporting through this growing crisis
and joins me now
from delhi amrita another day and
another deadly record for infections
that's right bad numbers coming out of
india
now another record as we said the number
of new infections today
a record of the number of deaths in
delhi and high positivity rate of 21
across the country hospitals are
overwhelmed as you mentioned
and in fact the chief of the army staff
has met the prime minister
and he's offered military hospitals even
for non-military personnel so the
reports i'm hearing is
uh that also the military hospitals are
pretty full to capacity
in another development uh some 350
scientists have appealed to the
government
to provide the most scientific data for
example the sequencing of
these variants and mutants tracking
clinical results from vaccines how
people are testing
they say they need this what they call
granular data to get a better sense of
what this crisis is like
another grim reminder of what we are
going through right now is this
the hospital beds and oxygen that we are
running out in delhi
but also space information grounds and
burial grounds
there's simply not enough space for the
number of bodies which are being brought
in
and amitay in the midst of all of this
india is also set to begin vaccinations
for anyone above the age of 18 from
saturday
how prepared is the government
not very well as it turns out it was
much touted that
on the 1st of may everyone over 18 could
be vaccinated
as it turns out there's simply not
enough vaccine supplies
under india's federal structure the
government of india
allocates a certain number of vaccines
to each state
and the rest the states themselves must
procure and some of the states find they
don't have enough vaccines
and they're thinking of now either
delaying or postponing
uh the start of this expansion of the
vaccines
and some cities like mumbai
have stopped vaccination all together
for three days because they have no
supplies
so it's quite a setback for the
government because vaccination was a key
pillar
in their strategy to bring down and
break down the chain of transmission
and bring down the numbers and other
countries are also helping in
there is a lot of aid that has poured in
is this
enough amrita or does the government
need more aid
well the government and prime minister
modi've always been very proud of their
self-resign
reliance but this time in their hour of
need they are very happy to
welcome aid coming from some 40
countries some of the areas already
started coming in
some still on the way but the critical
thing is how fast can they use this aid
and take it to people
who need it most that is still a
critical question because time
is of the essence is this aid enough
with this crisis of this scale and a
country this large i think
always more aid
thank you very much for the dw news
bureau chief in delhi please
stay safe
the deadly chaos of the second wave of
coronavirus infections
is in stark contrast to the first last
year
india dealt with that by imposing what
was called the world's
strictest lockdown india streets fell
empty and coronavirus case counts
dropped eventually seemingly contrary to
warnings about the danger india faced
even before the coronavirus spread
around the world epidemiologists warned
that india could see the worst of it
some of the most crowded cities on earth
coupled with an ailing health care
system
foreshadowed disaster but the first wave
of the pandemic seemed to have spared
india
at the end of march 2020 prime minister
narendra modi ordered a total lockdown
of the entire population
for three weeks the most severe step
taken anywhere in the world at that
point
it appeared to be a success by the
beginning of summer the country of 1.3
billion people
was still recording a small number of
daily cases
when monsoon season hit cases rose
steadily peaking at over 90 thousand per
day
but in october with the virus in decline
government scientists speculated that
india had reached herd immunity
modi spoke at the world economic forum
at the end of january declaring the
virus defeated
where 18 of the world's population lives
has saved the world
entire humanity from a major tragedy
by effectively controlling corona
when india began vaccinating it took
pride in exporting vaccines
to other countries in need
then came spring and with it the spread
of two new coronavirus variants
british and indian cases began rising
the government imposed some restrictions
but millions
gathered to celebrate the holy festival
of colors and kumbh mela
at the ganges river
india's second wave was swift and
unstoppable
the case count in april has doubled
every 10 days
an exponential curve
even the most optimistic models predict
india could see another month
of this before the second wave peaks
dw correspondent nimisha jaiswal joins
me now from delhi nimisha
you've been in the thick of this
deepening crisis speaking to patients
doctors what are they saying will things
get worse before they get better
for patients it's simply a crush to find
treatment we've seen people
being carried to the gates of hospitals
completely out of breath
being told that there is no room they
cannot be helped
for relatives of these patients they're
scouring social media twitter and
instagram
looking for beds medicines and oxygen as
well
for those relatives who managed to get
their loved ones admitted into a
hospital
that is considered a victory already
doctors are under immense
stress they insist that they will
continue striving on
but with cases pouring in every day in
thousands this in itself is a massive
challenge
they do point out to me that india had
let down his garden that could be why
this wave is as massive as it is but
without
resources coming to them they are
scrambling as well to not only treat
these patients
but to even give them necessary
medicines and oxygen
speaking of india letting down its guard
back in january prime minister
narendra modi had said that india had
shown the world how to
effectively battle the pandemic what do
indians now
say to that claim
well is pretty safe to say that there
has been criticism
almost across the spectrum not just
journalists and the opposition but many
citizens as well
have come out to ask what exactly
happened
how did we make such massive mistakes
for example
there were warnings that supplies of
oxygen should be shored up
but clearly they were not there is a
crisis on going in
every major city and we are hearing that
rural areas
are being hit very hard as well but i
think most concerning for many people is
this government's
firm denial of any admittance of a
mistake that they may have made in the
handling of this crisis
as as as recently as march the health
minister
of india had said that india has entered
the end game
of the pandemic and earlier today he
pointed out that india has the lowest
fatality rate
there are concerns that if you do not
acknowledge a problem
you cannot solve it do indians then
trust their government
indians will follow curfew they will
mask up they will respond to
restrictions they will respond to
appeals to get vaccinated
but the trust element may well be
diminishing
so far in political discourse in this
country most people are firmly
entrenched into either cap that supports
the government
or those who criticize and oppose it now
more and more we are seeing supporters
of the government also question
what exactly happened here how did we
get here a tragedy that's affecting
virtually every indian let me show yes
while in delhi thank you very much
and stay safe
you're watching a special edition of dw
news on india's coronavirus crisis
still to come in the program researchers
around the world are trying to find out
all they can about the b-161 coronavirus
variant
circulating in india but just how deadly
is it and what can be done to prevent
its spread
the coronavirus pandemic is having a
massive impact on india's public health
system
but what about the mental health impact
of people who are not sick with the
virus
we speak with young indians trying to
cope
dozens of countries around the world
including the uk the us and russia are
sending
aid to india planes carrying oxygen
generating plants
ventilators anti-viral drugs and
protective equipment for india's health
workers
have been landing in india for days the
european union has activated its civil
protection mechanism
and is also sending shipments of
medicine and equipment
to help fight the spread of coronavirus
in
india
let's bring in uh yannick lenachuch the
european commissioner
for crisis management he joins me now
from brussels mr lenatic welcome
what kind of support is the eu providing
to india
india requested assistance in the
following forum
they asked for oxygen oxygen devices
like concentrators generators and
cylinders and
antiviral medicines as well as
ventilators
upon receiving such a request we have
immediately activated our civil
protection mechanism
we reached out to all member states of
the european union
and we have received extremely generous
and quick response
by now more than half of eu member
states have already offered assistance
on these particular items that india
requested
what about vaccines scientists are
saying that india also requires
vaccines is the eu planning to send
vaccines to india
india has so far not requested vaccines
from the european union
our civil protection mechanism works in
the manner that we respond to specific
requests
and the specific request from india so
far has not yet included vaccines
is there a plan within the european
union that if india were to request for
vaccines
vaccines would be readily available from
the eu
i would not exclude that the fact is
that almost
half of vaccines produced in european
union
are being exported from day one so
european union has already displayed
solidarity with the rest of the world
and i would not exclude its readiness in
the future to also share
its vaccines can you put a number on
this readiness to share vaccines how
many
millions of doses can the eu spare at a
moment's notice
i don't have the current number but i do
know that
about 150 million doses have been
administered so far within european
union
and almost the same amount of vaccines
have been
exported from the european union
including to the so-called kovacs
facility which is intended to provide
the vaccines to 92 low and middle income
countries all over the world
there are also crawls growing for
vaccine technology
know-how to be shared with other
countries that can produce these
vaccines is the eu
open to sharing that technology
the european union supports
collaboration
and voluntary licensing in order to
ramp up the production of the vaccines
initially
the big issue facing europe as well as
the world
was limited production capacity this has
now been
improved also through the measures like
collaboration
and licensing are you worried that
uh the kind of uh pandemic that we are
seeing
deepening every day in india will
potentially harm
india's uh the the supply of vaccines
that
india can deliver to uh the rest of the
world including the eu
is that a concern in the eu right now
we are concerned uh because of the
situation in india very much first of
all because of the situation affecting
indians themselves
but second also because india is one of
the biggest if not the biggest
producer of vaccines worldwide and
until the current crisis india
has exported tens and tens of millions
of vaccines produced in india to
other parts of the world these exports
have now stopped
and this may have the negative impact on
the availability of vaccines in
in large parts of the world so we are
concerned uh
and we will try to find a way to to make
up for that
yannick le naches the european
commissioner for crisis management thank
you so much for joining us from brussels
a new double mutation of the coronavirus
in india has been partly blamed
for the rapid increase in cases it's
said to be more infectious and deadly
than earlier variants
here is what is known so far about it
the west indian state of maharashtra is
where the b1617 variant of the
coronavirus was first recorded
in december 2020
the strain has two mutations on its
spike protein
that's the bit of the virus that gets it
into our body's cells
both genetic mutations have cropped up
before around the world in other strains
of the coronavirus
and when they did they were linked to
the virus passing between people more
easily
they were also linked to the virus being
better able to get past the body's
defenses
seen a systematic increase in cases
across india
more or less taking off at the same time
suggesting that
what might be happening is that
something that is more transmissible
between people
is very rapidly moving through the
population of people who are yet to
contract the infection
and therefore spreading faster but how
quickly does this new type spread
to get a handle on that researchers need
to be able to see when people have it
and when they die from it which means
sequencing the viruses genes
that research has been extremely limited
so far in india
out of millions of cases in this new
wave only around
a thousand sequences have been published
meanwhile scientists across the world
are working to find out how deadly b1617
is
as the number of people dying continues
to rise
their answers can't come quickly enough
join me now for more is dr lancelot
pinto a pulmonologist and epidemiologist
at the renowned hinduja hospital in
mumbai
dr pinto welcome do scientists in india
have enough data to be able to
understand
the b161 double mutant variant
no i i don't think we have enough data
and i think far more sequencing needs to
be done than what is currently done to
really understand the transmission
dynamics
uh to understand whether it's been
associated with re-infections
whether you know questions around immune
escape questions around
virulence and questions around
transmissibility i think we have very
limited information at the moment
but dr pinto why is that i think the
first reports of this
virus became available in october last
year then again in december and then in
march earlier this year
the government in fact released uh had a
press release
why do we not have scientific data as
yet
i think to a certain extent that's
limited by the expense
associated with whole genome sequencing
my understanding is that it's not very
inexpensive to do but yes you know a
part of that is because i think
maybe the gravity of knowing these
mutations is not fully comprehended and
understood
because it may not necessarily convert
to treatment outcomes or
implications immediately but one has to
be far sighted when it comes to these
kinds of things
you are a doctor who's working with
covert 19 patients on a daily basis
what is this variant doing to the body
that's making it so deadly
so i'm not really sure whether it's more
deadly than the first time around but uh
we do know for a fact that it appears to
be a lot more transmissible than the
first time around
so the first time around when the
average rate of infection among close
contacts was about 10 to 15 percent
uh which meant that in a family of five
or five for
every five individuals who were exposed
to a patient one would get infected
this time around we are clearly seeing
entire families entire work spaces
people attending a marriage ceremony for
example a significant proportion of them
turning positive which
suggests that it's highly transmissible
and i think when that denominator
becomes as
huge as it is right now even if a small
proportion of individuals need
hospitalization need intensive care that
converts to a
to a whopping number and i think that's
what we're really seeing i don't think
they're absolutely convinced that it's a
more lethal
variant of the virus yet given how
transmissible
this is are there any actions that
people can take
to avoid getting infected
i think viruses are known to mutate
coronaviruses are going to keep mutating
with time and i think the most efficient
way to prevent that
is mass and rapid vaccination so i think
if you vaccinate enough individuals
you prevent this constant cycles of
transmission and transmission is
eventually associated with
mutants uh you know this is called
selection pressure mutants that
that develop if people are vaccinated
enough and that transmission cycle is
broken
uh i think i think we would succeed in
preventing the emergence of new
mutants and variants you want to see
mass and rapid vaccinations how hopeful
are you
that that will happen given the vaccine
stock in the country
not very hopeful at the moment but i
think things are changing you know i
think uh there's
there's aid which is coming from the us
the u.s is sending us a whole stock of
vaccines which you're very optimistic
and hopeful about
i think there were certain supply chain
hurdles which have kind of which have
been cleared at the moment
and hopefully that will allow us to ramp
up production i think the government has
also
provided some sort of an incentive in
terms of funds to the vaccine
manufacturers
to scale up uh if they do it fast enough
i think there is hope around the corner
i think the other vaccines have also
been put on a fast track for approval
so the more the number of vaccines that
enter the country i think greater the
probability of
of us being able to scale up vaccination
what is your honest prognosis doctor do
you think case numbers will continue to
rise in india
before they stabilize are we still
awaiting the peak of infections
so i know for a fact that the state of
maharashtra the state in which
eye practice is kind of plateauing out
over the past four or five days
it does appear that the number of new
infections appear to be plateauing out
of course we know that mortality deaths
then tend to lag by about two or three
weeks so
you know unfortunately i think the need
for critical care
beds the need for ventilators has still
not beat unfortunately in the city of
mumbai
uh if you look at the trends from last
year the city of
the state of maharashtra and the city of
mumbai were the worst affected initially
and then the rest of the country
followed suit
but so did the recovery patterns so
based on the recovery patterns that i'm
seeing in mumbai
and in the state of maharashtra you know
there is reason to be optimistic
that within the next two or three weeks
hopefully the rest of the country will
follow as well
dr pinto could a lot of the horror that
we are seeing currently
have been prevented with better
preparation
i think mistakes were made all around uh
i think
in hindsight a lot of people probably
regret
a lot of things that they did in terms
of lowering their guard in terms of
gatherings that that occurred which
which possibly should not have happened
given the fact
that we know over the past one year that
uh
gatherings of people in close spaces in
crowded spaces and close contact of a
whole bunch of individuals
is the most efficient way of spread so
in hindsight i
i do think that we could have done a
better job in preventing
um spread at a mass level at an
individual level as well i think we got
very optimistic and complacent
after the numbers went to an all-time
low in the months of december and
january
after we survived through diwali after
we survived through new years without
seeing spikes
i think all of us collectively let our
guard down and i i think we're paying
the
price for that so yes this could have
been prevented to a certain extent
um but i mean that's what we're
realizing in hindsight now unfortunately
dr pinto i can't imagine the stress you
and your colleagues
are having to work under on a daily
basis
how are you and your colleagues coping
i think all of us are stretched thin
over the past year i think we don't see
light at the end of the tunnel which is
very
which is a very difficult circumstance
to work under when
you know every time you see a glimmer of
hope unfortunately there is another wave
that that pulls you down i think i think
all of us
are close to our uh to to the end of our
patients to the end of our resilience
uh i think all of us are a lot more
irritable and a lot less patient than we
used to be last year
um but but that's just the way it is i
think
talked to lancelot pinter pulmonologist
and epidemiologist at hinduja hospital
in mumbai
thank you so much for joining us and
thank you for the work that you do
thank you for having me
as dr pinto alluded to the india's
coronavirus health emergency masks
another medical crisis that's been
bubbling away
hidden from view from the last year
itself the
impact on the mental health of its
people repeated lockdowns
death illness is taking a toll across
all age groups
in all settings urban and rural but with
a sizable population of young people
the impact is especially hard on them
breakdowns fear anxiety these are the
words 29 year old kanika uses when asked
about how she's coping with the second
wave of kobit 19.
both her parents are covet positive and
her father has been in the hospital
for days personally for me it's been an
emotional mayhem
in this second wave my dad became a
victim and a very serious one
and it just made me realize how crazy
things are at the moment kanika runs an
online mental health platform mind peers
which connects people to therapists
and the statistics are enough to tell
her that she is not alone
apart from anxiety depression and grief
that many are already experiencing
she says a lot of young people may end
up suffering with ptsd
or post-traumatic stress disorder last
year
there were about 50 to 60 therapies that
were coming in
in one day and right now from the last
three to four weeks at least that has
touched 250 or a day
the second wave has been catastrophic
images of people
gasping for breath and collapsing in
front of hospitals where no beds or
oxygen are available
have impacted the mental well-being of
many
some experts are convinced this wave has
triggered a mental health epidemic of
its own
therapist shreita srinivasan says many
young people who come to her feel
hopeless and anxious
over an uncertain future we're all also
collectively going through a traumatic
space right now with the pandemic our
bodies are responding with
anxiety with numbness with overwhelm
and which means that none of us is
prepared to handle
an event as traumatic or as difficult as
this on a global scale
srinivasan adds that being constantly
connected with the world online and
accessing new information
while helpful is also impacting the
country's youth
by the second we're getting updates from
um hospitals symmetries crematoriums
of these very very triggering very
distressing images
of people who are sick and dead and
grieving families and
it's obviously affecting us i don't
think it's an experience that
any of us will ever recover from yes we
need help
as we recover from this yes we hopefully
more and more people will seek
help when it comes to their mental
health
hopefully it'll increase conversations
about it
both arushi and shaitan have been doing
what they can to help
by amplifying requests for emergency aid
on social media
they say that while there is an
overpowering feeling of helplessness
there is also some optimism in the way
young people have been mobilizing help
in these times for kanika it is her work
at mind pierce that has been helping her
cope
when i come back from the hospital in
the evening i'm just working
because i know if i'm not going to
distract myself i'll just cry
as she struggles to maintain a positive
mindset
she is doing everything she can to bring
her father
back home soon
and joining me from bhopal in central
india is dr anand paan a public health
policy expert
dr bhan welcome now you have been
looking at the mental health impact
of the coronavirus emergency in india do
you think
young people are particularly vulnerable
thanks for having me yes absolutely
young people are certainly
quite vulnerable you know this has been
an extended year much more than a year
of
lockdowns uh you know stoppage of
schools
colleges just a lack of certainty on
when things will improve they've also
seen a lot in lots of cases
illnesses within family losses within
family perhaps not being able to reach
out to friends and meet them in the way
they were able to have support systems
earlier
there have been increasing cases of
domestic violence and
all of that obviously has a tool
especially now i think with
the increasing number of cases the
negativity all around
the visuals they're seeing on tv it is
adding to the mental health tool
i'd like to talk a bit about the
frontline workers the medical
professionals doctors
nurses medical attendants who are
literally at the front line of this
crisis and have been
for more than a year we were just
talking to a doctor from mumbai who was
trying to explain to us what they go
through on a daily basis
what is the impact on medical health
professionals such as these
well there is a lot of anxiety there is
some
palpable fear as well they have seen
many colleagues get infected
they know that they are taking great
personal risk in offering care obviously
but
you know given the kind of profession
they are in they obviously prioritize
patient care over
their personal well-being but it does
come at a cost because every day when
they go back home they are fearful about
taking
back the infection to their families
many of them live with young ones many
of them live with
elderly family members and it is quite
stressful you know we've seen many
health providers unfortunately dry
during this pandemic
and you know many of them continue to
get sick
and they don't really have a breathing
space because there is a shortage of
health professionals
so every day they have to go and do work
in these kind of stressful situations
where
it's a matter of life and death almost
every minute and to have to take
decisions around triage
around saying no to individuals when
there is not a bed available not enough
oxygen available
can be incredibly traumatic do people
have any recourse
to help or assistance
well you know it helps obviously to talk
about it
people are also you know reaching out to
other professionals a lot of mental
health professionals have stepped up
and are trying to be available you know
everyone's uh
trying their best to be able to be there
uh these are
incredibly uh tough times for everyone
but
uh you know the health provider
community uh the larger community of
frontline workers i think everyone is
trying their bit to try to help out
the fact that you know this is a
situation which warrants
uh this kind of a response is is unique
but also unfortunate
india has barely one psychiatrist for
every hundred thousand citizens clearly
india is under equipped to deal with
mental health
i'm wondering if you think that this has
not been
a priority area for the government in
the past
well mental health has been historically
neglected globally not just in india but
even in india the numbers
clearly show that the mental health
burden is really not known very well
because
it's not been studied adequately many of
my colleagues have been working for many
years trying to
come up with data to show how important
mental health is and try to then
come up with a response as you were
rightly saying part of the issue is that
specialist parents can supply so if you
rely on models which only
require psychiatrist or psychologist to
be available it's going to be very
difficult to
offer mental health care in a country of
india size and population
what might be more useful to look at are
models where there is task sharing where
you can work with frontline health
workers
train them to offer first-line mental
health care and then build referral
mechanisms there is now enough evidence
that this kind of work can be very
useful for mental health care provision
especially at the primary care level
talk to me a bit about the rural areas
of india i mean the urban areas
still at least have some sort of mental
health care facilities there are at
least some psychiatrists there what what
about the rural
areas of the country in the villages in
the hinterland
what is the situation sorry the
situation there
yeah so psychiatrists and psychologists
can be difficult to find you know you'll
be lucky if you have a psychiatrist at a
district level
if they are there they usually at the
district hospital not
lower in the health system there are
some medical officers who might have
been trained
to offer preliminary care but in most
cases patients with
mental health conditions are either not
identified and if they are identified
they are usually referred up
where there can be a loss because not uh
not every patient who's identified will
go to a district hospital or to a
tertiary care medical center
the models which we have worked with
other colleagues have come up with in
south asia
involved training frontline health
workers such as antenatal midwives
such as accredited social health
activists activists so that
frontline health workers at least are
able to identify those with mental
health conditions offer
care to the to an extent possible and
then refer those who need more
specialized care
this way you don't end up having to
spend send everyone who's identified
with the mental health condition to a
specialist
but you are able to provide care more
closer to the community
that is at a policy level but just at an
individual level
dr ban what can people do to tackle
their fears
and anxieties
yeah well there's there's lots of things
people can do certainly one is just
being cognizant of the amount of
information and misinformation which is
being shared
um having support systems around them
having trusted people they can speak to
as well as knowing if they are having
persistent symptoms of any kind which
might indicate that they have a mental
health
issue of any uh that they should go
ahead and access care
there is a lot of stigma around mental
health also which needs to be broken
including in our communities
it just in the same way we would access
care for a physical ailment
we should feel comfortable seeking help
if we have a mental health issue
dr anand we'll leave it there for the
time being but thank you so much for
joining us from popal
thank you for having me
india's second wave is a tragedy that
has hit nearly every indian
including this one it's a tsunami that
overwhelms the country
every day in case numbers that's more
than 380
000 just in the past 24 hours
relatives trying to arrange oxygen for
their loved ones trying to arrange beds
trying to arrange medical supplies most
of the time
failing in the process
the fires burn day and night
but delhi's morticians are barely able
to keep
up these makeshift crematoriums
have become a symbol of india's kovid 19
catastrophe
this was a parking lot but we got
permission to set up an extra
24 crematorium sites and now there are
so many corpses
we're running out of firewood
[Music]
kovid 19 has taken an enormous toll on
india
many died because there was no one to
take care of them
for days there have been lines of
patients in front of hospitals
no one lets them in because there aren't
enough beds
or oxygen tanks people feel abandoned
and my father is in a very critical
condition i'm getting no help
numbers are given there but nobody is
responding
numbers are not reachable please help me
please
my father is dying i can't afford
another loss i
yesterday i lost my younger brother my
father
my father begged me to help him but i
couldn't do you know how that feels when
your own father cries
and all you can do is put him in an auto
rickshaw without an oxygen tank
for three days i've been walking from
one hospital to the next
i've never seen anything like this in my
life
the doctors are aware of these
catastrophic circumstances
but they can't do anything about it one
hospital director told dw news
the situation is out of control i'm
used to making decisions and getting
them implemented
but i feel so helpless now i get more
than 500 calls every day
from people asking for beds asking for
oxygen asking for help
many people are scared and want to get
vaccinated
but there isn't enough vaccine to go
around
even though india is the world's largest
vaccine producer
there's not enough for its own citizens
we don't have any more vaccines please
leave
please cooperate with the police
prime minister narendra modi has
promised help to overburden hospitals
but many say he is to blame
he held election rallies despite rising
infection numbers
and he allowed huge religious festivals
like the kumela to go ahead
this is now seen as a super spreader
event
all of this gave a common message that
it does not matter whether you keep
distance between the people
or you you don't wear masks so
all of that complacency i think has
backfired
the consequences are catastrophic india
urgently needs help
an international assistance effort is
underway
but for many it's already too late
dw correspondent marina chaudhary is in
delhi manira
you've been reporting through this
crisis in fact we just saw your report
on mental health
just earlier in the program i would i
wonder
how have you fared through this pandemic
well i'd like to say that it's hard to
maintain a sense of calm
and even a sense of detachment from your
new stories when you are in the thick of
the situation we are
all going through this we are in the
middle of this and the kind of images
that we have been seeing
people desperately struggling to survive
families breaking down in front of
hospitals
crematoriums are overburdened families
are jostling and struggling to perform
the last rights of their loved ones
these are bound to affect you so yeah
obviously i have been having my own
share of anxiety issues
especially because i know i'm a
journalist i am aware i understand what
the situation
is right now i know how difficult it is
so that does make me anxious for my own
health
for the health of my loved ones and i'd
like to say that a lot of people of my
generation are going through these
issues and
including people from the media
fraternity and you see a lot of this
coming out when you open a social media
platform say
instagram people are pouring their
feelings out there and one word which
has been coming
uh up and across a lot from a lot of
people
when you speak to them about their
mental health and even uh when someone
speaks to me about my mental health
right now that word is apart from
anxiety that what is that of
helplessness
you do feel a very overpowering sense of
helplessness in this situation and even
though people of my generation
youngsters are using social media and
trying to mobilize help there is still
an overpowering sense of helplessness of
not being able to do as much
as we could to help because uh clearly
the health infrastructure
is not even on the brinks of collapse it
is almost
collapsed right now so there is a big
sense of helplessness here
i wonder if there's also a sense of
abandonment but just
paint us a picture of what it's like
living in the national capital
of the biggest democracy on the planet
where the federal government has advised
people in delhi to wear a mask even at
home
well it is uh quite panicky i would say
if you
talk to anyone your friends your
acquaintances uh
your colleagues it is a sense of panic
there is a huge sense of concern right
now because we can see that
even if you do get infected uh we do not
have a lot of support we can't really
rely on the medical infrastructure on
the health infrastructure right now
because there isn't a lot of support
left over there so yes uh when we talk
about living in the capital city
right now there is a lot of panic there
is a lot of anxiety
people are concerned about stepping out
right now people are concerned about
finding
the right medical help at the right time
which could actually
help save someone's life right thanks so
much
sorry to interrupt you thanks so much
for joining us you've been watching a
special edition
of dw news on india's coronavares crisis
thank you so much for watching
you